>> From the Library of
Congress on Washington DC.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Good
morning, I'm Stephanie Marcus,
from the library's Science,
Technology, and Business Division.
I'm really excited to welcome you
to the first lecture
of our 2017 series.
We'll have eight more,
and this is the 11th year
of our collaboration
with NASA Goddard.
So we're going strong, and as
you can imagine will never run
out of topics.
Our speaker today is astrophysicist,
Julie McEnry, and she
is from Ireland.
She was named Fermi Project
Scientist in 2009 and works
with all elements of the mission.
Before that, she was the analyst --
oops, the analysis coordinator
on the large-area telescope,
which is Fermi's primary
science instrument.
She was named one of Fermi's
deputy scientists in 2005.
Along with her work at NASA, she has
been an adjunct professor of physics
at the University of Maryland
College Park since 2009.
So she's a very busy lady.
Dr. McEnry has touched down many
places during her academic career.
She started off with a degree
in physics, with astrophysics,
from the university of Manchester,
and then received her PhD
from University College Dublin.
She did postgraduate work in Dublin,
followed by the University of Utah.
That was quite a distance away, and
the university of Wisconsin Madison,
and was a Fermi research
scientist at the University
of Maryland Baltimore County.
We're really excited to have
Julie McEnry land at the Library
of Congress today to take us on a
journey into the extreme universe.
Please help me welcome her.
[ Applause ]
>> Julie McEnery: Thank you very
much for that nice introduction.
It's really a pleasure to be here.
I would first like to say
that your buildings are nicer
than our buildings at
Goddard Space Flight Center.
I think it's 50s and 60s
architecture versus earlier.
So what I would like to talk
about today is a snapshot of some
of the results from the Fermi
Gamma-Ray Space Telescope
that I think are exciting.
I'm not going to try cover
everything, because you don't want
to be here for four or five hours.
But I do think that
in the last 10 years,
we've opened up an entirely new
way to look at the universe.
We've found exciting new things.
We answered questions that
we have, but we've also,
more importantly, opened
new questions.
What you see on the image there
is the map of the gamma ray sky
with an artist's sketch
of the observatory.
The main instrument, the
large area-telescope,
is actually that squared
box on the top.
We're very much not a
traditional telescope.
So let me begin.
If you go out to the sky at night
and you look up, you'll see stars.
At the right time of the
month, you'll see the moon.
You know where to look, you
can see planets slowly moving
through the sky.
And if you're in a
dark enough place,
you'll see the faint glow
of our Milky Way galaxy.
But if you had gamma ray vision, and
he stood on the ground and look up,
you'd see nothing, because
gamma rays don't get
through our atmosphere, but
if you could propel yourself
above our atmosphere and look
at the sky with gamma ray eyes,
you would see a drastically
different place.
The Milky Way, which in optical,
is faint and dim, a small glow.
In gamma rays, it's blazingly right.
More than 85% of the gamma rays
we see come from the Milky Way.
They're produced when particles
moving at close to the speed
of light smash into molecules of
gas and light photons in our galaxy,
producing this enormously
bright glow.
This image of the sky is
an galactic coordinates.
So what you're seeing is the
very bright Milky Way galaxy
across the center, and
I've scaled this image
so that it doesn't overwhelm
everything else that you see.
It's very, very different.
If you continued to look
at the gamma-ray sky,
you'd notice that the moon is
brighter than the sun and neither
of them are really bright at all.
In addition to the radiation,
the gamma rays that we see
from our galaxy, you'd also
see many point sources,
individual sources of gamma rays.
So one example, but I'll talk
about in a little more
details of are pulsars.
These are rapidly spinning neutron
stores with enormous magnetic
and electric fields that accelerate
particles to extremely high energy
and produce bursts of radiation that
rhythmically are beamed towards us.
We also see a phenomenon
known as blazars.
This is the most populous
source in the gamma ray sky.
So again, if you're looking at
the sky in optical wavelengths,
the kind of astronomy that
we've been doing since the time
of the Babylonians,
most of the things
that you see are stars and galaxies.
In gamma rays, most of the things
that we see are things known
as an active galaxy, where you
have a super, massive black hole
at the center of the galaxy,
and we're looking at that subset
of objects where a jet of particles
moving to close to the speed
of light is pointing in our
direction and beaming and focusing
that radiation directly at us.
We see gamma ray bursts.
A gamma ray burst is the most, or
at least until the LIGO discovery,
one of the most energetic
phenomenon in the universe.
When we see a gamma ray
burst, we see a small flash
of gamma rays blasting
from a fraction of a second
to around 1000 seconds,
and what you're seeing
when you're seeing a gamma rays
burst is the birth of a black hole
in a very distant galaxy.
And I think one of the other things
that are particularly interesting
about the gamma ray sky is a
lot of it is not well-known.
At any given moment, about a
third of the things that we see
in the sky do not have
a confirmed origin.
In some cases, it's because
there's several candidate options,
and in other cases, we really just
don't know what the object is,
except that it's producing
gamma rays.
So it must be exciting.
I'm not at all biased.
So let me tell you a little
bit about what a gamma rays is.
A gamma ray is the highest
energy form of life.
So if you're familiar with
the electromagnetic spectrum,
you'll know that it
starts at long wavelengths
and low energies at radio.
As we increase the energy
or shorten the wavelength,
we pass through microwave,
and optical,
and as we increase
the energies again,
we get to x-ray, and
then to gamma ray.
But what I think is worth pointing
out here is this is
what our eyes can see.
A very, very small swath of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
It's very important,
because we all see it,
but this is what Fermi can see.
The amount of range
of wavelengths covered
by Fermi is enormously broad.
So while it's all called
gamma ray, that band,
that part of the electromagnetic
spectrum is extremely large.
And why you care about this?
Well, if you think about it, if
you take a photograph of your hand,
you have a photograph of your hand.
If you take an x-ray of your
hand, you see the bones.
And as you view your hand or the
universe at different energies
or different wavelengths, you
get different information,
and it's just the same in astronomy.
That if we view the universe in
gamma rays, we see different things.
We focus on different things.
We learn different things than
when we make our observation
with the more traditional
x-ray and optical
and infrared and radio wavelengths.
So there's two examples
on this chart.
The top shows how the sun
looks in different wavelengths.
The sun is actually quite
an important object for us.
We see it all the time,
but when it flares,
it can briefly become an
extremely bright gamma ray source.
And then on the bottom, just to
illustrate how things look different
in different wavelengths, there
are infrared to x-ray image
of something holding an iPhone.
So how do we detect gamma rays?
I told you we have a
really strange telescope.
There's no mirrors in gamma rays,
because the gamma rays would
just go straight through them.
What you have to think about is
how gamma rays actually interact
with matter, and you
might have heard
of Einstein's famous
equation E equals MC squared.
And what this is telling
us is that energy
and matter are fundamentally
the same thing.
C is the speed of light,
which is a very large number.
So if you multiply mass by very
large number, it equals energy,
but a very large amount of
energy, and what's special
about the wavelength, the energy
of the gamma rays that we looked
at in Fermi, is that there's enough
energy in each individual gamma ray
to produce an electron and
the anti-particle to electron,
the positron, in our detector.
So we're using this phenomenon
to detect our gamma rays,
and we're using them because
we're converting the gamma rays
from energy into matter, and
then we're tracking the motion
of that matter in our detector.
So large-area telescope is this box.
So what happens is a
gamma ray comes in.
It's minding its own business,
and the remarkable thing
about gamma rays is that, really,
the universe is very
transparent to gamma rays.
So this gamma ray, well, I mean
that's just a line on the screen,
but if it was a gamma ray, it
will have gone through millions
and millions of light-years.
It can go straight to our galaxy,
but as soon as it comes close
to the earth, it's
just going to go splat
because the atmosphere
will absorb it.
If it hits our atmosphere
first, what will happen is
that the gamma ray will
interact to produce an electron,
and the anti-particle to
the electronic, the proton,
indicated in those purple lines.
Our detector contains
instrumentation
that can precisely
measure the position
of the electron and positron.
So we measure the tracks of
the electron and positron,
and by reconstructing where
those tracks came from,
we can figure out where the
gamma ray turned into matter
and where it must have come from.
At the bottom of our detector,
we have a material
node as a scintillator.
A scintillator produces an amount of
light that's related to the amount
of energy that was deposited
in it, and from that,
we can measure the
energy of the gamma ray.
So now we know where
the gamma ray came
from We know what it's energy was,
so we can, gamma ray by gamma ray,
build up a picture of the gamma
ray sky, one gamma ray at a time,
making our gamma rate map deeper
and deeper and deeper with every day
that the mission continues
to make observations.
It's an extraordinary instrument.
We have over a million channels
of electronics, but we power it,
all of this, with something
like a hairdryer.
We're an international instrument.
The instruments on Fermi
were built in Japan, Sweden,
Italy, France, and Germany.
And the logistics of keeping
all this together while we were
under a strict schedule
was quite a challenge.
So I picked a few interesting
fun facts.
At the time we built the
large area telescope,
we were the largest silicon detector
in the world, larger than anything
that was built in the particle
accelerators at CERN or Fermilab.
This was enough silicon to make
almost a million digital cameras.
We collect information from
a million different sensors,
several thousand times a second, so
our instrument is reading out very,
very quickly all the time.
It's the equivalent of an
instrument that is taking an image
of the sky thousands
of times a second.
But this is all powered by
the equivalent of a hairdryer
with power generated by solar
energy, and interestingly, in space,
our issue isn't actually our
ability to generate power.
We have no problem with that.
We've got large solar panels,
but in the vacuum of space,
is challenging to get
rid of the heat.
So we went to a lot of effort
to design extremely
powerful-efficient electronics.
And our energy range, as of already
mentioned, is extraordinarily broad.
So we take the large-area
telescope, and here's a picture
of the instrument in
Phoenix, Arizona.
It's the silver box on the top
and the spacecraft is just below.
At that point, the solar
panels haven't yet been added.
We then put the spacecraft
on a rocket.
So this is a picture
of the spacecraft now
with the solar panels installed
onto the ferry in Florida.
It's a very nerve-racking moment.
You spend 10 years of
your life loving leak,
carefully putting together for size
and extremely expensive
instrumentation, and then you put
on top of an enormous amount
of extremely flammable fluid
that is uncontrollable
once it's ignited.
And you cross your fingers
and hope for the best.
So many of us took this photo
the night before launch,
as we couldn't sleep.
So before I show you the next few
charts, to put things into context,
something that we didn't realize at
the time is that there was an offset
of a couple of seconds
between the video feed
and the audio feed at launch.
So we're waiting for launch,
and the countdown happens.
It's five, four, three, two, one,
and we have lift off,
and we saw nothing.
And then a couple of
seconds later we saw that,
and that looks quite bad.
So for the briefest moment, a lot
of people's hearts dropped totally
into their chest, but
then of course,
it was actually completely fine.
And all that was really happening
here is there was a larger
than normal amount of water
flow underneath the rocket
that you flow water underneath a
rocket at launch to stop the pad
from being destroyed,
we just happened
to have a particularly
high water supply.
So that isn't smoke.
It's steam.
Okay, so let me tell you a bit
more about we've actually seen.
So this is our sky above 1 GeV.
I've shown it to you before.
At GeV, is a billion electron volts.
A GeV is a billion electron
volt, and an electron volt is
about the energy of
normal optical photon.
So what you're seeing here,
every single gamma ray
in this image has an energy that
is a billion times the energy
of the photons of light that
are entering our eyes right now.
But we got a broad energy range, so
I can also show you a map of our sky
above 50 GeV, 50 billion
electron volts.
And what we see in the sky
changes slightly just as it does
when you look at the sky in infrared
and you look at the sky in optical.
Some objects go away.
Some appear, but the
thing I really want you
to notice are those two large lobes.
I think I can do this.
Large lobes above here
and down here.
These were completely unexpected.
They're unusual, because
they're appearing
at only the highest energies.
That's telling us that
they're being produced
by very high energy particles
are gamma rays are produced not
by heating something up
to a very high energy,
but by accelerating charged
particles to close to the speed
of light, and the more accelerated
particles get, the higher the energy
of gamma rays that you produce.
So if we see these large,
faint lobes appearing
at the highest energies,
what it's telling us is
that there's a population of
particles of electrons or protons,
we don't know which, in our
galaxy that have accelerated
to extremely high energies.
These lobes are really
quite extraordinary.
They loom over above and
below the galactic center,
extending for 25,000
light years above
and 25,000 light years
below the galactic plane.
If your eyes were sensitive to gamma
rays, the Fermi bubbles would extend
over almost half the sky.
They would absolutely dominate
the sky you see at night,
and we had no idea that these
existed until we had Fermi,
an instrument that was sensitive
to the photons dominantly being
produced by the Fermi lobes
over a field of view that's large
enough to map them completely.
If you were to turn the
Fermi bubbles on their side,
they would envelop us, but they
don't, because they're perpendicular
to the plane of our galaxy, and
of course, we lie in our galaxy.
So we're -- well, you can
see the label of the sun.
There's lots of things
extraordinary about this.
The total amount of energy in the
Fermi bubbles is equal to somewhere
between 1000 and 10,000 supernova
all going off at the same time.
The energies of the individual
gamma rays are extraordinarily high.
This, I think, is one of
the most unexpected things
that we could ever have found.
So what do we think it is?
Well, first, before I go to that,
let's -- another couple of --
this is one of the early maps that
we used to find the Fermi bubbles,
and there were two features.
The first I've already described is
that the Fermi bubbles have
higher energy gamma rays than most
of the rest of the
emission in our galaxy.
So they stand out when we
make a map of higher energies.
They also have sharp edges.
So the sharp edges are important,
because the sharp edges suggest
that they were produced
by some transient event.
That something happened that
produced a shock wave that went
out into the intergalactic
medium, blowing up the bubbles.
So now the question is, well,
what could that possibly be?
To think about this, you need to try
and imagine where is a good place
to produce a lot of energy?
Well, we know that the center
of our galaxy contains a
supermassive black hole.
It's not active at the moment.
It's quiet.
It's quiescent.
We know it's there, because we
can see the pattern of the stars
as they orbit the center
of our galaxy,
but what the Fermi bubbles are
telling us is that somewhere
between 1 to 3 million years ago,
the center of our galaxy
was not quiet,
and there are two possibilities.
One is that the black
hole itself became active.
That perhaps some star
has dropped in,
and you had a large accretion
event that produced the same jets,
the relativistic jets, the
particles moving close to the speed
of light beamed into a
narrow jet was produced
when this creation event happened.
Or, perhaps, you have
a large burst of stars
that all form at the same time.
The large stars will live a very
short life and will go supernova
at the same time, and
that's another way
of producing enormous
burst of energy.
Or perhaps we have both.
That initially you have a large
burst of star formation followed
by creation onto the black hole,
produce a jet that then continues
to power and energize this
shock as it extends out.
It's relatively recent.
So once, 3 million years
ago, humans were on Earth.
So in astronomical terms,
I mean, this happened like,
you know, just the other week.
So I think it's very exciting to
have concrete evidence that are
at the center of our galaxy.
The black hole at the center
of our galaxy did not behave
in the recent past way
that we see it now.
Okay, so let me tell you a little
bit about how we make observations.
This is supposed be an animation.
There we go.
So we got a huge field of view.
The field of view of our
instrument, we see about 20%
of the sky at any instance.
That's about what your
eye is [inaudible].
So what we do is if you
imagine, you just look,
you're going around the earth,
and you just always point
yourself away from the Earth.
You'd sweep out a swath of
the sky that cover about 80%.
We're not interested in
seeing only 80% of the sky.
We want to see the whole sky.
So what we do is we
tilt North for one orbit
and cover the northern
hemisphere, and we tilt South
for the second orbit to cover
the southern hemisphere,
and what you see in this bottom
right-hand chart is the coverage
of the sky over those two orbits.
We see the entire sky
every three hours.
And that's particularly important,
because the gamma ray
sky is highly variable.
Gamma ray bursts are popping off,
are active galaxies, are flaring,
sometimes by changing their
flux by a factor of 100
on time scales of hours or days.
So here what I've done
is taken the Fermi sky
and taken the northern hemisphere
and put it on the left-hand side
and the southern hemisphere and
put it on the right-hand side,
and the very bright galactic plane
is now a little bit suppressed.
So you can see the other
things that are varying.
Most of the things that you're
seeing are active galaxies.
Super-massive black holes at very
large distances from us, with jets,
relativistic jets, jets with
particles moving close to the speed
of light pointing directly at us.
You'll also notice that there seems
to be a source running around.
This image is -- this movie is made
of the sequence of
one-day snapshots.
So this is what our sky
looks like every day.
The object that's running
around is the sun.
So, I mean, we can see it.
It's not, you know, it's
not that it's not there,
but it's certainly not as
bright as the optical sun.
I mean, imagine trying to take an
image of the sky when the sun is up.
You certainly wouldn't
see any stars.
I did mention earlier that the
moon is brighter than the sun,
but of course, of these
timescales, the moon is moving
through this image
much more quickly.
So you're not seeing the
moon, because it's smearing
across a larger number of pixels
on an integration time of a day.
So I'm going to switch
gears a little and talk
about one type of object.
So if you start -- the
Earth is kind of small
in the grand scheme of things.
It's very important to us,
but we're really kind of tiny.
And I'm showing this just to give
you a sense of the scale of size
between the sun, the
moon, and the Earth.
And I'm telling you this
because I want to give you a feel
for how much -- how
large the sun is.
Now imagine taking the sun and
compressing it to something
that would fit inside DC.
You'd have enormously
high densities.
When you compress things, you
also compress the magnetic fields.
So you end up with a
magnetic field that's more
than a million times more intense
than anything we can
produce on Earth.
So now you have something
that's incredibly dense,
with an incredibly high magnetic
field, and we spent rapidly.
And by rapidly, think of
something like a ceiling fan.
I mean, can you imagine something
that is the mass of the sun,
the size of DC, and spinning
as rapidly as a ceiling fan?
These are really extraordinary
objects.
So it shouldn't surprise us
that this is the kind of place
that gamma rays can be produced,
because when we're
reducing gamma rays,
we're looking for extremes
in the cosmos.
We're looking for extremes
in magnetic fields,
extreme energy, extreme
acceleration.
We don't, in general, see stars in
gamma rays unless they're exploding
or have exploded and they're in a
more energetic phase of their life.
So what you're seeing
here is an animation
of a rotating neutron star,
just to give you the sense
of how you're going to
see a sequence of pulses
from the emission be produced
at the two magnetic poles.
Neutron stars are produced
in solar explosions.
So you produce a neutron star
by starting with a normal star
at the end of the star's life.
It stops the nuclear burning.
The material collapses on the
center into a huge explosion,
and the remnant of this is either
a black hole or a neutron star.
So this brings me to the very first
result that we had with Fermi.
So October 16th is
our publication date,
which means since we
started operations in August
that this first result was based on
our first couple of weeks of data.
What you see on the left-hand side
is the grayscale, is a radio image
of the supernova remnants CTA1A.
A supernova remnant
is the outer bits
of the shock that's produced
when the star explodes.
The blue circle is the
size of the uncertainty.
So we knew that there is a gamma
ray source here, but we didn't know
where it was better than the size
of this blue circle from six years
of observation with the
previous instrument.
The red circle shows how well
we could pinpoint the location
of this source with Fermi
after just two weeks of data.
The red source lies right
on top of an x-ray source.
So it's clear, at this point,
that the gamma ray source
and the x-ray source really
must be the same thing.
So the gamma ray is being, in
this case, were not being produced
by the supernova remnant.
They were being produced by
whatever that x-ray source was.
Well, what makes this really
interesting is that when we looked
at the data, we realized that
the pattern, the arrival time,
of the gamma rays was not uniform.
That every 316 milliseconds, we
were seeing the same patterns.
So what you're seeing on here
is zero to 316 milliseconds
and then were just repeating
the same thing again.
And this is telling us that for each
rotation of this star, this source,
is rotating at 316 milliseconds,
and that the gamma rays are arriving
at the same point in
this rotation each time.
So it's telling us
that this is a pulsar.
But it's not a pulsar in radio.
It's not a pulsar on x-rays.
This was a pulsar shining only in
gamma rays, and that was telling us
that we were never seeing the full
sample of pulsars in our galaxy,
because before Fermi, we didn't
have an instrument that was able
to find most of the pulsars.
And they're important, because a
pulsar is the end stage of a star.
So if we want to understand
the full lifecycle of a star,
you have to understand them
from the birth right the way
through to the death,
and this is the death.
So this is an early degree
of PowerPointmenship.
So this is -- we've taken a bunch of
the early pulsars, manually put them
onto the plot, and then
manually added an animation
that is flashing 10 times
slower than the actual pulsar.
But it illustrates what
we have in the sky.
So CTA1 was just the
first of many pulsars
that are found only in gamma ray's.
We have over 60 that are
shining only in gamma rays.
About a third of the pulsars that
we know of shine only in gamma rays.
We've also found 60 normal pulsars,
the ones that are also
shining in radio.
But you also notice on this image
that there's pulsars in pink
that look like they're
just doing -- they're not.
They're going very, very fast.
Those are millisecond pulsars, and
those are a special kind of pulsar.
They're pulsars that reach the
end of their lives, slow down,
then they accreted material from a
companion that sped them up again
until they were, again,
turned on his pulsars.
They're known as millisecond
pulsars.
They're very special objects,
and they're very special objects
because they're excellent clocks.
So one of the things that Fermi's
been able to do that over half
of the known millisecond pulsars
have been found from Fermi searches.
And what we use millisecond
pulsars for is
that you've got something that's
spinning very, very, very regularly.
So it's an excellent clock so if
you imagine you've got a very large
gravitational wave coming
through the galaxy that's
distorting space/time,
it's going to slightly move the
arrival time of the radiation
from these millisecond pulsars, and
we can use that to chart the passage
of very large gravitational waves.
So with this, we can create a galaxy
-sized gravitational wave detector.
So this is just one
example of what you can do
with the millisecond pulsars.
We have another mystery.
So this is not gamma rays.
This is an optical image of our
galaxy, and the animation that I'm
about to show is going to zoom in
towards the center of our galaxy.
So this is close to the center.
So not like the Fermi bubbles.
Hang on. We need to
actually play it.
As we get closer, this animation
will superimpose what we see
at the galactic center.
And as the animation
continues, all of the known ways
to produce gamma ray's
will be subtracted.
Subtract the background.
We'll subtract the point sources,
and what you get left with is a blob
about 10 degrees in size
that is also unexpected.
It has an unusual spectrum,
and by spectrum,
I just mean the distribution
of energies off the gamma rays.
It just peaks between 1 and 5 GeV.
A supernova remnant
doesn't behave like that.
A pulsar can, but a pulsar
isn't 10 degrees in size.
So this is one of the second
mysteries that we have
at the center of our galaxy.
That the center of our galaxy
is special, because that's
where the largest gravitational
sync is.
You might have heard of
the mystery of dark matter.
That there is a material in
our galaxy, there is material
and galaxy clusters beyond what
we can actually see radiating.
And our colleagues from
particle physics tell us
that the leading candidate for
dark matter, because it solves one
of their particle physics
problems, is a new particle
that when it encounters
itself, will produce gamma rays.
Where would you expect to find the
most dark matter in our galaxy?
Right at the center.
How would you expect
it to be distributed?
You'd expect it to be
distributed in a blob.
What would you expect
the spectrum to be?
You'd expect it to be peaked
and have a sharp cut off related
to the size of the
dark matter particle.
So one exciting possibility is that
what we're seeing here is a signal
of dark matter in gamma rays.
If we look at our neighboring
galaxy, Andromeda.
So this is a very recent result
published earlier this year,
we found the same thing
in Andromeda.
So what you're saying
on the left-hand side,
the contour lines chart where
the gas in that galaxy is.
If the gamma rays in
Andromeda are produced
by very high energy
particles smashing into gas,
then the gamma rays should
be following the pattern
of those lines.
And it is not.
The gamma rays are concentrated
at the center of that galaxy.
So like our galaxy, Andromeda has
in an anomalously bright
emission of gamma rays.
Like our galaxy, Andromeda sees
the same distribution of energies.
So whatever we see in the center
of our galaxy is not unique
to our galaxy, but is a
phenomenon that's likely present
in all normal galaxies.
So this is potentially very
exciting, and it, you know,
we're still excited at the
prospect of this being dark matter,
but you have to always
consider other possibilities.
And now that we know that
there's a large number of pulsars
in our galaxy, it's possible
that we've a large population
of millisecond pulsars around
the center of our galaxy,
and from my perspective,
it doesn't really matter
which of these perspectives
are correct.
I think it's incredibly
exciting that the center
of our galaxy had activity
several million years ago
that we didn't know about,
and that now the center
of our galaxy contains components
that we didn't know about.
I'm going to switch
gears completely.
Everything I've spoken
about so far our data
from the large area telescope.
That's this box up at the top.
But there's other instrumentation
on Fermi.
We have the gamma ray burst monitor.
It's an array of instruments.
There's three here, one
here, another three,
and the same on the other
side of the spacecraft.
And his instrument is designed
to detect flashes of gamma rays
at lower energies then the Fermi
telescope, but large-area telescope.
So what kind of things do we see?
Well, a gamma ray burst,
I've already mentioned,
is the birth of a black hole, either
because two neutron stars merge
or a neutron star and
a black hole merge,
or a large star has an
extremely energetic supernova.
There's an object known
as a magnetar,
and a magnetar is an extremely
high magnetic field neutron star,
and when you crack the crossed
and have a sudden large release
of magnetic energy, you get
a large burst of gamma rays
that the whole star is shaking.
So the gamma rays are coming
out in a periodic motion,
but this periodic motion
isn't telling us
about the rotation of the magnetar.
This periodic motion is telling us
about the structure and the interior
of the star, just as the sound
you get from a bell is determined
by the material of the
bell and its shape.
We can use the time, the pattern
of the signal from the gamma rays
from magnetars to explore
the interior structure
of a neutron star.
We see gamma ray flashes
from the sun,
less now that the sun isn't
active, and the topic that I want
to focus on, because I
thought I'd do something other
than astrophysics, or thunderstorms.
Because the Fermi gamma ray burst
monitor sees the entire sky,
most of it is the sky, but
the earth is underneath us.
So we don't see the
sky through the earth.
We see the Earth.
And when the spacecraft is
over regions of the earth
that have thunderstorm systems,
we quite often see a very short,
brief flash of gamma rays,
lasting just milliseconds,
with a very characteristic spectrum,
very characteristic
distribution of energies.
And if you plot these
unusual transients in the sky,
you'll find that they
lie on top of regions
where there were thunderstorms.
This was the moment where I learned
that thunderstorms
happen largely overland.
I think it's kind of
obvious from this.
But what's interesting is a handful
of them show very unusual
properties.
So we had a situation where
the spacecraft was above Egypt,
and we saw one of these
terrestrial gamma ray flashes,
flashes of gamma rays
produced in thunderstorms.
But there wasn't any thunderstorms
in Egypt, but there were
in Tanzania, and if
we look at the --
there's two things I
want you to look at.
The first is the --
on the left-hand side,
what you're seeing here is
time on the x axis and counts,
number of gamma rays on the right
excess, and what we saw was a peak,
and then it came down, and then
we saw another little peak.
And that's unusual, but what
I really want you to look
at is on the right-hand side.
On the right-hand side what you
see is energy along the x axis
and the number of gamma rays
on the right on the y axis,
and this sharp spectral feature.
The energy of that
bump is at 511 KeV.
That's exactly half the
energy of an electron.
What's happening here isn't that
we're seeing gamma ray's directly.
What's happening is the positrons
are directly hitting the instrument,
are converting.
It's a positron is the
antimatter particles, the electron.
They're hitting electrons
in our detector,
and they're doing the
opposite of the pair conversion
that I spoke about before.
So E still equals MC
squared, but in his case,
we're turning the matter
back into gamma rays,
and then we're detecting those
gamma rays in the instrument.
This also was a surprise.
So you go back to the drawing
board and you think, well,
what was -- what's going on here?
So this image shows a
thunderstorm on Earth.
The moon is there just for context,
and in the thunderstorm,
the pink are gamma rays.
So what you have is
an enormous amount
of acceleration in the thunderstorm.
The thunderstorm is
accelerating particles.
The particles are producing
gamma rays in the atmosphere.
But the accelerated
particles, when they move --
when particles move
in a magnetic field,
they have to follow the
magnetic field line.
So the charged particles are
in yellow can't spray
out in all directions.
They are following the
magnetic field line.
So we move onto the next
animation, now you can start
to get a sense of what happened.
The thunderstorm happened
in Tanzania.
You've got a pulse
of charged particles.
This is a pulse of
electrons and positrons
that are traveling along the
magnetic field line thousands
of miles, hitting our spacecraft.
And they're continuing along
the magnetic field line
until they reach the conjugate
point, at which they bounce
and come back and hit
the spacecraft again.
So this is the same
kind of phenomenon
that keeps charged particles
in the Van Allen belt.
I find it quite amazing to realize
that even if you're thousands
of miles away from something, that
a thunderstorm is affecting us
by sending antimatter directly to
us from thousands of miles away.
So I'm almost finished.
I'm not going to talk about all
the other things that we do,
but we have done and continue
to do extraordinary things.
So what I'm showing here, starting
on the bottom left, close to us,
and going up to the top
right to most distant
from us are all the
astrophysical topics
that Fermi has produced
a press release on.
Everything in yellow are
things that were not known
as gamma ray emitters
before the launch of Fermi.
So we have it just seemed
more gamma ray sources.
We haven't just measured known
gamma ray sources more precisely.
We have understood the
energetic universe in a way
that we had no idea
before launching Fermi.
This has opened our
eyes and hold new ways.
And I am pleased that we are
able to address the questions
that we said we would address
when we launched the instrument,
but I think, as a scientist, what
makes me most excited about Fermi is
that we've raised new questions.
We know the Fermi bubbles
exist, but we don't know
yet precisely what causes them.
We know that we've got an excess of
gamma rays in our galactic center,
but we don't know what
that excess is.
I could have given this talk and
covered a completely different range
of topics, and I sometimes do,
and I think they would've been,
at least to me, just as compelling
as what I've described to you here.
So I think my summary is
to say that, you know,
really there's much
more to the universe
and we can see with our eyes.
This is true on earth just as
much is it's true in the cosmos.
My day job is extremely exciting,
because our observatory is
constantly scanning the entire sky,
and the sky is constantly changing.
So there's always something
new to fine.
I talked about two unexpected and
different features in our galaxy.
We have huge lobes of tens of
thousands of light-years in size,
and then we have this unexpected
blob right at the center
of our galaxy, both of which
have potentially extremely
exciting explanations.
The first is that the galactic
center was not as calm and quiet
in the near past as it is now,
and the other might be a signal
of dark matter or might be
telling us about a whole population
of objects close to the center
of our galaxy that we know about.
And there's a ton of things I
didn't discuss, but what can you do?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Thank you, so much.
We have time for some questions, and
I will ask Dr. McEnry to repeat them
so everyone can hear them.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Julie McEnery: Yes, so when
a gamma ray is just traveling
through a vacuum, it's
going to stay gamma ray,
but when a gamma ray passes close
to the electric field of a nucleus
or to another photon,
in that scenario,
then you can have a
physical interaction
that converts the gamma ray into
a matter and antimatter pair.
The matter that's produced
is related
to the energy of the gamma ray.
Electrons are like.
So that's about mostly
what's produced,
because we don't have gamma
rays that are large enough
to produce any other particles.
So now we have two
charged particles.
We have an electron, which you've
probably heard of, and the positron,
which is the anti-particle
to the electron.
The electron has a negative charge.
The positron has a positive charge.
The silicon in our
detector produces a signal
when a charged particle
goes through it.
So with each layer of silicon in the
detector, we're pinpointing the path
of that electron and positron.
So if you imagine, you see
the electron going this way,
the positron going this way,
you draw a line between them,
and the gamma ray then
just has to come from where
that line kind of averages out.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Yes, so the place, the other place
where we see this quite commonly is
in the detector that I just
described to you here is very,
very similar to kind of
detectors that they build
in the particle accelerators,
and in fact,
that's why this mission is a
partnership between the Department
of Energy and NASA, because we
work with the particle physicists.
So the other place where you
have these kinds of detectors
and you're measuring the
same phenomenon is places
like the Large Hadron Collider
in CERN, and in that case,
they're smashing protons
together, and in that collision,
they're also producing
high-energy gamma rays
that are having exactly the same
phenomenon in the detectors at CERN.
That they're producing
electron-positron pairs,
and the physicists there can
do the same thing that we do,
reconstruct to figure
out how energetic those
individual gamma rays are.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Please repeat the question.
>> Julie McEnery: Ah, sorry.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I have one.
Is this mission going to continue
and continue for many, many years?
>> Julie McEnery: So the question
is will this mission continue?
And we do not have anything
that is consumed on board.
We have a propulsion system, and
there's a requirement that you have
to have a propulsion system -- if
you don't have a propulsion system,
you have to design your mission
so that you have to de-orbit,
I think, within 15 years.
Because we have a propulsion
system, we're and an orbit
that will remain valid for
science taking until at least 2050.
Our performance now, almost
10 years after launch,
is actually a little bit
better than it was at launch,
because we find how
we process the data
so this point we will continue
making observations for as long
as it is scientifically, and every
three years, we are reviewed,
and that determines whether we
continue on it in the future.
>> So what about high-energy solar
flares that you did not discuss?
>> Julie McEnery: Okay, high-energy
solar flares are interesting for us
because one of the results that
I didn't have an opportunity
to discuss -- so here's a picture
of the sun during three solar
flares that we saw with Fermi.
And what's amazing is that these
images were taken by stereo.
Stereo, you can see
the back of the sun.
So this is not the part of the
sun that's facing the earth.
This is the part of the sun that's
facing away from us, and yet,
we saw a bright flash of gamma rays
lasting about two hours associated
in time with the outburst
that you see in this movie.
So what must be happening is that
the sun, when it has a flare,
it's throwing material way
out into the solar system.
Those particles, like I
discussed with the TGF,
follow the magnetic field lines
long enough that the particles,
the energetic particles, are
now far enough away from the sun
that we can actually see
them directly from Earth.
So this was -- I mean, one of the
real things that we've learned is
that when the sun flares, it's
kicking material very far away,
and that the particles in the kicked
out material are being accelerated
to extremely high energies.
And we wouldn't have known that
if everything was coming straight
for us, because we can't tell the
difference between gamma ray's
that are produced right at the sun
and produced kind of halfway to us,
if it's all in the line of sight.
In this particular case, it was
telling us that the geometry
of how the gamma rays are being
produced is not what was expected.
>> How energetic are they?
>> Julie McEnery: These, the gamma
ray's in each of these three flares,
these were very, very high energy.
So these ones were actually
seen by our main instrument,
the large area telescope, and
they extended up to a few GeV.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
The gamma rays are absorbed in
our atmosphere in the same way
that they're absorbed
in our detector.
So the gamma rays come in, and they
will interact with or pass close
to an atomic nucleus
in the atmosphere
and produce the electron-positron
pair.
And in fact, if you look at gamma
rays that are much higher in energy
than the ones that we do, that
process produces electrons
and positrons that are
themselves very energetic.
Those electrons and
positrons interact
and produce more gamma rays,
and the gamma rays interact
to produce more electrons
and positrons.
You've got a cascade of particles
moving through the atmosphere.
So before I moved to NASA
and started working on Fermi,
I worked on instruments on the
ground that detected the particles
that are produced in the shower,
and if the initial camera has a high
enough energy, then some remnant
of the gamma rays' passage
through the atmosphere is
still there at ground level.
And what we do is measure the
particles that reach the ground,
and from that, figure out
where the gamma ray came from.
>> You mentioned gamma rays
being created by lightning.
Have you detected gamma
rays coming, therefore,
from group storms on Jupiter?
>> Julie McEnery: We have not.
We have looked, but if you were to
scale the intensity and then move
out to the distance that
Jupiter is at, we wouldn't expect
to see gamma rays from thunderstorms
on Jupiter, unless they were much,
much more intense than
the models predict.
Yeah?
>> Have you seen these
bubbles coming off the center
of other galaxies?
>> Julie McEnery: So the question
is have we seen the bubbles
from other galaxies?
And the answer is maybe.
It's hard to see them from --
I mean, we're not able
to see very far away.
We do see large gamma
bubbles from Centaurus A,
which a large radio galaxy.
Actually, if I go back to
an image, I can show it.
Of course, if I go back to it,
I won't be able to find it.
So Centaurus A is a
source that's just here.
But it's not quite the same,
because the Centaurus A contains
a currently active black hole
with a relativistic jet.
So it's possible that
what we're seeing
in Centaurus A is something that's
in the process of making
the bubbles.
But we have not seen
the gamma ray bubbles
from any other galaxy
that's calm and quiet.
But for the same reason that we
don't expect to see thunderstorms
on Jupiter, if you were to
take the intensity of emission
from that we see from our galaxy
and move it to how dim it would look
if you put it in another galaxy, in
most cases, it would be invisible.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
So the question is how fast do gamma
ray convert from energy into matter.
How fast to the resulting
particles move?
And the answer is it depends
on the energy of the gamma ray.
If the gamma ray has just enough
energy to produce the electron
and positron, then the electron and
positron will actually be at rest.
If the gamma ray has more energy,
then the resulting electron
and positron will have more energy,
and energy is directly related
to how fast the particles
are moving.
So the speed of the electron and
positron that are produced depends
on the energy of the
camera a that produced it.
And in most cases, the electron
and positron are, themselves,
are moving at close
to the speed of light.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
If it stops, you probably
consider it --
you would be immediately absorbed.
I think you would see it, but
you wouldn't measure much.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Is that everything?
One more.
>> [inaudible] me.
Doctor, you might have
mentioned this.
Is there a -- are you able to
discern patterns in outbursts
that could be dangerous
to the earth?
Even with solar flares,
would that be [inaudible]?
>> Julie McEnery: Yes, so it
is certainly the case that,
and we joke about this, that the --
a gamma ray telescope is
almost like an anti-study.
That anywhere that could
produce gamma raises going
to be extremely inhospitable
to life.
Some of the phenomenon I described,
if the radiation was produced by --
if that same phenomenon
happened close to us,
it could be quite severe.
So there's a couple of examples.
The magnetar, which I
described with the GBM,
some of those magnetars have --
when the magnetic crust cracks
and you have this huge release
in energy, these objects are
in our galaxy, and the
radiation that we see
on earth can be sufficiently
high that it would knock
out electromagnetic communication.
We haven't had one of these
out bursts in about 15 years,
and in the past 15 years,
our electromagnetic infrastructure
has greatly increased.
So could we tell you that
something bad was happening,
you need to protect yourself?
Probably not, because the by
the time we see something,
the bad has already happened.
However, we could tell you
what the problem had been,
and I think that actually would
be in extremely important.
So if our communication systems
were suddenly knocked out,
it would be very helpful to know
that it was an actual astrophysical
source that caused that.
>> Have you seen anything that could
suggest burning all life right off
the planet?
>> Julie McEnery: So the
second example would do that.
On the left-hand side
is a gamma ray burst.
And we see gamma ray bursts
from the edge of the universe.
If they gamma ray burst
happened in our galaxy,
and the radiation was
beamed towards us,
it would damage life very severely.
Not necessarily directly, but
it would change the properties
of our atmosphere sufficiently
severely that if you didn't die
in the immediate radiation exposure,
life on earth would be very
difficult for some time afterwards.
Now there are some hypotheses
that the age of the dinosaurs,
that it is one of the candidate ways
that dinosaurs stopped being around.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I hope no one
has nightmares after this lecture.
>> Julie McEnery: Well,
it has been a long time.
They're not that common.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Okay, I guess that's it.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.